when we think of becoming ruber rich
like billionaire level rich the only
solutions are to start a company and/or
be a wizard investor even that top paid
non founder CEOs don't crack the
billion-dollar mark so you wouldn't
expect a guy who starts off making
$50,000 a year and even at the peak of
his career making only 1.3 million per
year which is great but still 769 years
away from billionaire status to even
make 1 billion but Steve Ballmer was not
only able to make 1 or 2 or 3 billion
but 70 2.8 billion dollars ranking as
the fifth richest person an entire world
so here's the story of how he pulled it
off
starting off steve ballmer was a smart
guy who attended harvard way back in the
1970s after getting a degree in
mathematics and economics from Harvard
in 1977 Steve landed a nice job at
Procter and Gamble as an assistant
product manager meanwhile he started
pursuing a business degree from Stanford
but suddenly he had a change of heart
maybe it was a spirit of Silicon Valley
or some professor Stanford but he
decided to drop out and quit his job
with Procter and Gamble and join a small
start-up called Microsoft in 1980 now
Steve action knew Bill Gates from his
time at Harvard but during his undergrad
years he didn't feel that it was
necessary to drop out and pursue
Microsoft as a result he wasn't able to
claim a top level co-founder or
executive position so he had to settle
with employee number 30 when he joined
he didn't really have position within
Microsoft as they were still a very
young company and he would just help out
where needed his main tasks were to do
some accounting and hire new employees
but from time to time he would also cook
and wash bottles for Bill and other
executives and for his services Steve
was offered $50,000 a year and
eventually a share in Microsoft when
they become public Steve's first major
contribution to the company was during
Microsoft's first meeting with IBM
before the meeting Bill asked Steve to
join him in the meeting as he had a tie
and a suit and more business experience
than any of the other employees at
Microsoft so Steve just tagged along for
the first meeting but this first meeting
would quickly turn into several meetings
with IBM and Steve would help negotiate
a deal with IBM to run Microsoft
software on their computers this would
be Steve's first major contribution to
the company and though he was already
well-liked by his colleagues this would
solidify his importance in the startup
by the time Microsoft went public in
1986 Steve would own 8% of Microsoft and
this would be his ticket to billionaire
status meanwhile Steve was quickly
working his way up in the company's
hierarchy moving up the senior vice
president of
sales and support followed up by system
software and vice-president marketing
after about 18 years of the company
Steve would find himself as the
president of Microsoft after leading
several divisions within Microsoft at
the turn of the millennium as Bill Gates
stepped down from being CEO Steve
Ballmer would actually be promoted to
CEO now again though he would be the CEO
of Microsoft for over a decade this is
not where he would make his money he
owned a very nice one to two million
dollars per year but generally didn't
receive any stock during his time as CEO
however through the dot-com bubble the
8% stake he received way back in the
1980s would grow to be worth a few
billion making Steve Ballmer the second
employee in the world to become a
billionaire through stock options but
the good times didn't last long as the
dot-com bubble burst in the early 2000s
crashing Microsoft stock on top of this
many of the business decisions made
under Steve Ballmer would unfortunately
end poorly
for instance they launched the Zune
which was supposed to compete with the
Apple iPod but this was an utter flop
and most people don't even know that the
Zune was a thing
similarly the Xbox was meant to compete
with Sony's PlayStation and it was
actually quite successful in terms of
sales and revenue but the Xbox wasn't
very successful in actually pulling in
profits and of course there was the very
controversial Skype acquisition for 8.5
billion dollars but at least these were
just new endeavors from Microsoft and
their core business was still a dominant
well actually they were still very
dominating the operating system space
but this doesn't necessarily mean that
people like their new operating systems
Windows Vista was met with mixed reviews
but Windows 7 was actually quite solid
and then they released Windows 8 and we
all know what happened with that clearly
there are plenty of missteps under
Steve's leadership and when Steve
stepped down in 2014 Microsoft stock
would actually be 27% lower than when he
became CEO 14 years earlier given the
bleak outlook
Steve actually sold half his steak in
2003 after the.com crash now don't get
me wrong here Microsoft was unbelievably
profitable under Steve's leadership but
they basically filled in every single
attempt to diversify and expand as a
result when Steve left Microsoft had
basically reached its max potential and
other than their software and Xbox
they were quite irrelevant within
consumers minds they were simply no
longer the rapidly growing tech company
das explaining the reduction in stock
value and this is basically how they've
remained for several years from the
perspective of consumers but these past
few years have actually been the best
years of all time for Microsoft this is
thanks to their new focus on the cloud
market under Satya Nadella which has
quintupled their stock price in fact
there are all time highs right now with
a market cap of 1.5 trillion dollars
they've even claimed the number-one spot
as the most valid company in the world
several times over the past year and
this is what has allowed Steve Ballmer's
net worth to balloon to over 70 billion
dollars ironically all of the wealth he
made was literally when he was an
employee under Bill Gates or after he
retired as his Walt actually went down
significantly during his own leadership
of Microsoft thus Steve Ballmer is
literally the definition of in the right
place at the right time in fact if he
held on to his full a prescient stake
he'd be the second richest person in the
world today ironically is surpassing
even Bill Gates at 120 billion dollars
but then again bill would be worth 675
billion dollars if he didn't sell any of
your shares either what do you guys
think about Steve's journey to riches
comment down below and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one